aber das ist hier wo willst du hin
herzlich willkommen bei der begrüßung
ist er treu zusammen nimmt rolf könig
pur pass auf jetzt nur ein herz ganz
moment qi bitte nicht tut nichts
falsches ich bin nicht mag aber das ist
mir wie du dich verfolgst allein halbe
sets das ist bitte tut nix an das ist ja
jetzt gut so die tür die trend zu
wahrscheinlich 2001
das hatten sie noch im winter auf liegt
eine wand ich hab ja doch ich hab noch
nahrung okay jetzt kann jetzt kommen
andere seine sachen doch sichern was wo
das denn in der schiller lesen
check point click
wir finden im park elf von diesen köpfen
ich grad in der hand gelegt und wir
müssen
in jedem frei rollercoaster ding hier
ist ein kleiner kopf und wir müssen alle
finden
okay geben wir systematisch schaaf
schonte den bogen mit unendlichkeit
ok es tendenziell ob er denn the
painting to me von rollercoaster
stripper pulsader kann kurz atmen und
fast schon hin
das war das was ich am anfang gesagt
habe dass hier sonne unter wasser und
jetzt da nicht sehr gar nichts der
shader wo muss ich denn lang weiter
geradeaus jetzt rechts mein glück so
hier haben wir so ein held sowie den
muss jetzt abbauen
doch abbauen oder moped ok passt so ein
bekommen jetzt abgebaut ich komme nicht
an
ich verstehe diese kacani aber dass er
wolle das können wir auch kaputt machen
oder stimmend weiße wolle dürfen wir
kaputt machen
ich weiß nicht ob das stimmt aber
geschafft wirklich am anfang stand bei
der karte weiss wurde davon kaputt
machen wahrscheinlich auch bei den
sachen die wir übersprungen sind darüber
was weiße wolle so durfte mal alles
kaputt machen jetzt bisschen essen
herausgenommen danke schön bat ich hatte
ein bisschen was nicht ab 11 stück ich
habe im alter
du hast erhält ich habe es plötzlich
verlassen
ja da war bisschen was drin lollipop
dann lass mal hier vorne weitermachen
bei dem ihr wir gehen erwartetes fleisch
ich hab hunger vergiftung habe ich das
sind spinnen augen wahrscheinlich hat
toshiba creeper gespannt da bin ich
gespannt
nightmare beginn ein break zu schaffen
so geht's nicht weiter herunter das ist
ein glas teil habe ich wieder toll
kombiniert das glas teil ist doch mal
gesagt kommt also unsichtbare blöcke
siehst du die ja den kommentaren gelesen
ich sehe ich auch die geräusche
ich hab ich den aushängen oder ja ich
sehe schon die geräusche hier wieder das
war eine blöde doch das recht die ganzen
kopf einer hand so super schön raus und
jetzt war auch schwierig jeder abteil
wasser nach oben ist fast wie ein neuer
kopf leiter kopf läuft bei uns ja total
schon der dritte wir brauchen
letztendlich zählen aber die man
irgendwie elf macht man sich woher
zurück einfach in einer seite
theoretisch dann gewinner hier hin was
ist das denn sprungturm was kloster
tropper ja das ist ein erwartet den ko
im korb 3 1 bei 1 vorne kämpfen von
10,31 bei 18 kommt jetzt auch bei
einzelnen 1 bei marcell davis versichert
daneben nicht versichert das waren die
1&1 okay auf geht's wichtig die teams
ruderte truhe oder im übersehen auch
vater von der dass da das würde er mir
geht es gut ich gehe hin
nein er war drogba drin für das nicht
mehr die sind ja auf der spitze ist ja
in der spiel auf der spitze von dem
touren oder hochfest ist eine truhe die
muss zu bekommen ok ich du bist ja doch
hier unten ja klar wir wollen probieren
ich probiere jetzt ich schnappe mir
jetzt richtig komisch in den main katrin
ich kann gar nicht ausdrücken dass es
total verbuggt bei mir gerade
das ist nicht gut facto muss weiter
waren du musst schaffen
ja ich komme schon ewig ich in diesem
bereich
ich habe ihn ich hab den kopf die
behinderte ich in diesem mai katrin
sitze gab es geschafft die lage schon
spitzenteam dankeschön dankeschön das
hört man immer wieder gerne sondern in
den kopf fällt runter aber schon 4
die habe ich oben gelassen obwohl er ist
es keine gute entscheidung
jedoch gibt mehr ich gehe ich habe die
ersten gesetz muss sie erstmal im kopf
einfach immer wie viele köpfe hast du
dir hast du gerade den bekommen ich habe
vier stück ja alles gut
ich dachte mein kopf ist einfach einer
drin wechselt das war jetzt der straße
als auch den freizeitpark besucher auch
weil die gründen
man muss einfach das macht man das was
man muss ich sagen alles was dieser
mensch schneller macht es gut außer wenn
er sprungkraft wenn sprungkraft
involviert ist dann ist es klar
weiter wie zuletzt
ich habe die kiste gefunden ist eine
kiste ja ich auch nach langer star ja
schön dass es da mit currywurst und
bratwurst habe ich so bock auf
currywurst das mal möbel körpers tisch
legen was und guck was ist hier alles so
gibt lighthouse klein care müssen wir
plan b was heißt der lighthouse
übersetzt lichthaus begeister dings von
sony
lighthouse ist schon schlechter haushalt
der feierten so für sind sonst die
blöcke ja weil die lichtplanung zum
router schrank von gummi baustelle ich
denn immer direkt oder das kopf was ich
hatte falls command drin wenn man nach
oben gespielt zugrunde
quick so weit wie games geht raus muss
mich pforten
da ist im kopf
conny passt was hast du gut gemacht du
solltest darunter springt und was ist
ihr kopf wer gar nicht mitgenommen jetzt
schulen ja ich dachte nur hier im kopf
verbrauch braucht keine köpfe rollen der
schiedsrichter einen spitzen bisschen
schwimmen hält den kopf
bitte bitte so sechs köpfe haben wir
brauchen zehn oder sowas stand damals
peggy race up to for players are ja ok
oh ja es ist ebenso wie mario kart wii
schweine- rind- schweine- und was die
scheine hier kommentiert rezepte vor
sind die scheine
wir brauchen keine erwartet
uns fehlt doch eigentlich die karotte
noch oder läuft jetzt der salons jetzt
los muss dann ihren los button springen
buchen dingen jemand mal los naja
eigentlich fehlt doch noch die karotte
vorne dran kein schwein lauf falsche
richtung
okay okay naja was manchmal ja es geht
ich lauf lauf laufe und ich mein
schweigen was ist denn los mit diesem
schweinen und ja ich hab position ist
war gebe ankomme hektar das ist hier
kommt wo willst du hin er bat mich
einfach und gomez weiterhin auf
damit komme gewinnt so wie wir ihn an
war wirklich entspannen
da bekommst du komm raus lisa mader
befehl pardon
naja verdaulich warten oder so
nein das schwein bekommt ich hab
umgesattelt
okay ist langweid lauf doch lauf um dein
leben guck mal weil es das ist nicht
mein schwein das hat keinen sattel lauf
du fettsack das kommt nicht die treppen
hoch und da kommt ein okay aus
kaufbeuren schwein und ich führe mein
schwein ist wieder brutal gutes schwein
wurde schwein pig kommen jetzt um die
cor fja com bruder und um die kurve
driften hier kompakt dreifachen bonus
verderben mir das erst ruhe bitte
im kopf bitte bitte bitte bitte wird
witte und das der anfang
hier sind weit kommt schnell geschafft
hat den kopf warte mal auf mich und
schaue mich an der schweine prediger bin
ich ich wollte nur meinen scheint das
wenig verdeutlichen
ich mag kleine rund führung
kopfschuss ich hab die kopf springt
einfach drüber weg
dies hat das rek ap womit wlan kommet
klassiker einfach wieder raus ich habe
kopf genug komfort beim verwitwete
taster kopf geben sieben stück ok oh wir
mal noch einige sachen hier vor uns okay
sein dass da spaß
ich glaube vor glaube ich dir einfach
sieben helfer hamburg was aber nur wenn
alle köpfe hat komisch komme hat ja
keinen plan der macht immer sagt hallo
hallo einfach mal drauf da kommen hat
auch in dem bett geschlafen als er
aufstand dass man nicht schlafen soll ja
gestimmt das war stimmig das war okay
okay zehra explorer hier sehr verbot
er denkt der coach mit mir aufnehmen
fakt ist auch wieder start von parcours
kommen mal nach links irgendwo jetzt
verlieren wir die übersicht wenn wir so
handeln
guck mal nach links und dann kommt doch
wo ich bin bis zum anfang
das hier rein und jetzt hochspringen ich
dachte wenn schon da besondere spende
weiß wickeln oder ich mach das schon was
anderes job postbüro wenn ich schon lese
job postbauer denk mir auch sofort kann
nichts werden
auch da bist du ja ja sag dankeschön vdr
der jump uster tut richtig gut
halter das ist aber das letzte was in
dieser folge machen und dann seht ihr
den kampf um die letzten zwei köpfe und
um bis dato wohl wahrscheinlich um den
boss anschauen also weil wir haben schon
auf gesagt dass ich hätte der letzte
partner dann wird es noch mehr aber guck
mal hier ist er kommt gut an gedanke wie
wir den dingen steht einfach weiter luft
ich gebe meine letzten jahren nicht
gegeben hat bei kik komme wo man diese
möchte geflogen ist ja witzig alter
kommandant reubelt der geil jetzt haben
wir beide keine sprungkraft mehr als du
gut gemacht wie soll man braucht der
sprungkraft
so brachte es nicht getan
riesige scotland logo roland weißer oder
mussten wir eigentlich in die anlage in
die andere richtung müssen
es ist schon richtig gesagt bekommen
haben wir ja schon ja okidoki hat die
show knie aber das machen wir die
nächste vollkommen spitzen wäre gut
freut euch gefallen hat weit gefehlt wo
wir eventuell das ganze nennt werden
weil wir so gut sind in dieser map ja
total über profis mit